Usa el método de eliminación
para obtener "x" y "y".
Y tengo dos ecuaciones, "x" más "2y" igual
a 6 y "4x" menos "2y" igual a 14.
Y bueno, vamos a recordar que esencialmente,
el método de eliminación o de suma y resta,
lo que nos dice es que tenemos
que sumar estas dos ecuaciones,
tanto el lado izquierdo de estas dos ecuaciones,
como el lado derecho de estas dos ecuaciones.
Y si te das cuenta,
tiene todo el sentido lógico del mundo,
porque aquí tengo un más "2y"
y aquí tengo un menos "2y",
de tal manera que cuando yo las sume
me queda una ecuación con solamente una incógnita,
pues lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que
cuando yo sume más "2y" y a esto le sume "-2y",
estas dos se van a cancelar,
me va a dar de resultado 0.
Pero date cuenta que esto
tiene todo el sentido lógico del mundo
y es muy importante que lo entiendas,
si nosotros partimos de alguna de las dos ecuaciones,
supongamos la de arriba,
"x" más "2y" igual a 6,
tú has aprendido varias veces
y en varios videos y en varias clases,
que si tú sumas o restas una constante
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
la igualdad se mantiene,
porque estás haciendo la misma operación
de ambos lados de la igualdad,
por lo tanto sumar o restar una constante,
si se hace de los dos lados de la igualdad,
esto quiere decir
que la igualdad se va a conservar,
así que si aplico esto mismo a esta igualdad
y le sumo 14 de ambos lados de la igualdad,
entonces lo que va a pasar
es que esta igualdad se conserva, pero ojo,
lo que me dice la segunda ecuación es que
"4x" menos "2y" esto es exactamente igual que 14,
entonces en lugar de 14,
voy a poner "4x" menos "2y",
de la suma del lado izquierdo de esta igualdad
porque aquí hay algo muy importante,
lo que me están diciendo es que "4x" menos "2y"
esto es exactamente igual a 14,
este es el segundo dato que nos dan,
y como esto es igual a 14,
realmente cuando yo sumo estas dos ecuaciones,
lo que estoy haciendo es
sumando 14 de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y es justo en esto en donde me baso
que mi igualdad se conserva
y por lo tanto si puedo aplicar
este método de suma y resta, pero bueno,
ya que sabemos
que si funciona este método,
pues vamos a aplicarlo,
¿y qué me queda?
"x" más "4x" eso es lo mismo que "5x",
más "2y" menos "2y" pues estos dos se cancelan,
se van o se hacen 0, mientras que del lado
derecho me queda 6 más 14 lo cual es 20,
es decir que "5x" es igual a 20 ó si divido
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 5,
voy a poder obtener el valor de "x", es decir,
estos dos se van y "x" es igual a 20 entre 5,
lo cual es 4.
¡Perfecto!
Y bueno, ahora que ya tenemos
el valor de "x",
lo que hay que hacer es sustituir el valor de "x"
en una de estas dos ecuaciones
para obtener el valor de "y",
así que voy a usar la ecuación de arriba,
y dice, "x" más "2y" igual a 6,
pero "x" vale 4,
entonces me queda 4 más "2y" igual a 6
y si resto 4 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
estos dos se van
y me queda que "2y" es igual a 2.
Y ahora si divido entre 2 ambos lados de la ecuación, voy a obtener que "y" es igual a 1.
¡Y perfecto! ahora si ya tengo la solución
de este sistema de ecuaciones,
"x" igual a 4, "y" igual a 1
es la solución del sistema de ecuaciones o el punto 4, 1
es la intersección de estas dos rectas.
Y bueno,
ahora que tengo ya la solución,
sería muy bueno comprobar
que realmente esta sea la solución
y para esto lo que voy a hacer es sustituir el valor de "x"
y el de "y" en ambas ecuaciones
para ver si se cumple la igualdad.
En la primera ecuación me queda que
4 más 2 por 1 es decir, "x" más "2y",
esto tiene que ser igual a 6,
lo cual es cierto.
Perfecto, ya tengo una menos.
Y en la otra tengo que 4 por "x",
es decir 4 por 4 menos 2 por "y",
es decir, menos 2 por 1,
porque "y" vale 1,
esto tiene que ser igual a 14
y me queda 16 menos 2, esto es igual a 14.
Perfecto, también se cumple
la segunda igualdad.
Por lo tanto, la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones es "x" igual a 4 y "y" igual a 1.